buenas tardes la reunión entre china y
la unión europea no era una cualquiera
porque el contexto actual tampoco es
cualquiera el con el telón de fondo de
la guerra de ucrania la unión europea ha
insistido en ser muy clara en que la
equidistancia no es suficiente la
equidistancia ejercida hasta ahora por
chino y que tiene que jugar un papel
mucho más activo en parar esta guerra
sobre todo ha insistido la unión europea
en que china tiene un rol como miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad de
la onu y sobre todo por la indudable
influencia que puede ejercer sobre moscú
para que se sienta realmente la mesa de
negociación y de forma seria según la
unión europea no lo está haciendo
actualmente en su reunión la unión
europea también ha recordado el coste
que tiene económico que tiene para todo
el mundo esta guerra y el coste también
que provocaría que china decidiera
apoyar a rusia de hecho el 15 por ciento
de las exportaciones de china van a
parar a la a la unión europea tan sólo
el 2 por ciento de rusia y esta es la
carta que ha querido jugar hoy la unión
europea